thing you want to do is you want to move
the constant to the other side of the
equation just to get it out of the way
so let's go ahead and do that so we have
equals negative 10 and then over here
we're left with 1/3 x squared minus 6x
okay now what you want to do is you want
to factor out that leading coefficient
in this case is 1/3 so we're gonna
factor out the 1/3 this is going to be x
squared and this is going to be 18 x or
negative 18x and you're probably
wondering well if I'm factoring out the
1/3 why is this number getting larger
well you have to realize that when
you're factoring out 1/3 it's like
dividing by 3 and so you want to
counterbalance that by multiplying by 3
the nice thing is though you can check
your answer if you just distribute the
1/3 into the parentheses here 1/3 times
negative 18x gives you back the negative
6x so you know you haven't changed a
problem you just change the way that you
know that it looks so the next step here
is you want to complete the square and
so what you would do is you would take
half of this middle coefficient here
okay so 1 2 3 a half of the middle
coefficient and square it so half of
negative 18 is negative 9 and negative 9
squared is 81 now because this is in
parentheses this is really one-third
times 81 so out of thin air we're adding
1/3 times the 81 which is 27 to the left
side of the equation so to
counterbalance that we want to add 27 to
the right side okay so here with me so
far so then the next step is what you
want to do is you want to factor this
trinomial now because you're doing this
technique of cleaning the square this is
going to be a perfect square trinomial
it's going to be X and it's always going
to be half of this middle coefficient so
it's X minus 9 the quantity squared okay
so remember this is X minus 9 times X
minus 9 and you can foil that out and
you'll get this original quantity back
if you want to double check so then over
here if we add those together we get 17
okay so now we've completed the square
we want to solve for X we want to think
about working from the outside in
towards X okay by doing the opposite
operation so the opposite of multiplying
by 1/3 would be to multiply by the
reciprocal 3 over 1 so let's do that to
both sides so now we're left with X
minus 9 squared equals 51 okay and we're
still working from the outside in
towards the X so the opposite of
squaring is to take the square root of
both sides
now remember when you do that you get
two answers plus or minus okay the
square of the square root here are
cancelling one another out and then what
you want to do is you want to add nine
because that's the opposite of
subtracting nine but when you do that
you want to do that in front of the plus
or minus sign here on the right side you
don't want to say this is plus or minus
square root of 51 plus nine it's
actually nine plus or minus the square
root of 51